like we're just in a society where women  a lot of women are delusional okay or  because what's your level right anyone's  like level one to ten it's what you can  get to commit to you it's not what you  can sleep with and I think a lot of  times women like confuse the two and so  they'll they'll [ __ ] on average men like  like that's why we have in society we  have  I don't want no scrub like  but we don't have I don't want no whales  I don't want no fat chicks like like  they would be canceled immediately  and so everything in society it's weird  once you see it you cannot see it it's  like everything in society is empowering  women and pushing women forward and so  it it makes us narcissistic almost  because we think the whole world  revolves around us